rapport in his new book he details what
he sees as omissions and distortions
next on book TV it's an hour and a half
David Griffin let me say a few words
about the main sponsor of tonight's talk
mooch Gannett the Muslim Jewish
Christian Alliance for 9/11 truth that's
I on the web at mooch get calm that's mu
JCA
I know it's ugly I apologize and take
full responsibility
but it's mu J CA mooska I don't know
what language that sounds like it comes
from but i don't know if i want to learn
it in any case the Muslim Jewish
Christian Alliance for 9/11 truth wants
Jews Christians and Muslims and
everybody else who wants the monotheists
to stop killing each other to sit down
together and look at the facts of 9/11
whoever was responsible for that crime
it is clear they intended to sow seeds
of hatred and violence between the
Abrahamic faiths traditions we aim to
put an end to that hatred and violence
it is my pleasure here tonight to
welcome a man whose work on process
theology interfaith dialogue and
especially 9/11 truth represents a truly
historic contribution to this cause
ladies and gentlemen David Ray Griffin
thank you very much
it's my first time to university of
wisconsin-madison I've always heard this
as an extraordinary place but now I see
it's like that town in a neighboring
state here where everybody is
good-looking and far above average the
title of my talk tonight is 9/11 and the
American Empire
how should religious people respond I
will begin by unpacking those three
terms 9/11 American Empire and religious
people starting with the third although
I am a Christian theologian I am in this
talk addressing religious people in
general I am doing so because I believe
that religious people should respond to
9/11 and the American Empire in a
particular way because of the moral
principles of their religious tradition
that are common to all the historic
religious traditions I have in mind
principles such as thou shalt not covet
thy neighbor's oil
thou shalt not murder thy neighbors in
order to steal their oil thou shalt not
bear false witness against thy neighbors
accusing them of illicit ly harp
harboring weapons of mass destruction in
order to justify killing them to steal
their oil this language is of course
language that we associate with the
Abrahamic traditions Judaism
Christianity and Islam but the same
basic ideas can be found in other
religious traditions I turn now to the
term American Empire which has been a
highly contentious term in his 2002 book
American Empire Andrew bacevich points
out that it was long a cherished
American tradition that the United
States is not and cannot be an empire
the words American Empire he adds were
fighting words so that other uttering
them was almost a sure sign that one was
a left-wing critic of American foreign
policy but his base of itch also points
out this is all recently changed so that
now even right wing commentators freely
acknowledged the existence of the
American Empire as columnist Charles
Krauthammer said in 2002 people are
coming out of the closet on the word
Empire this new frankness often includes
an element of pride as exemplified by
Krauthammer statement that America is no
mere international citizen but the
dominant power in the world more
dominant than any since Rome given this
consensus about the reality of the
American Empire
the only remaining matter of debate
concerns its nature the new frankness
about the American Empire by
conservative
is generally accompanied by portrayals
of it as benign robert kagan has written
of the benevolent Empire Denis Sousa
after writing in 2002 that American
merica has become an empire added that
happily it is the most magnanimous
imperial power ever Krauthammer says the
fact that America's claim to be being a
benign power is not mere self
congratulation is shown by its track
record commentators from the left
however have a radically different view
a recent book by Noam Chomsky is
subtitled America's quest for global
dominance Richard Falk has written of
the Bush administration's global
domination project which poses the
threat he says of global fascism
Chalmers Johnson was once a conservative
who believed that American foreign
policy aimed at promoting freedom and
democracy but he now describes the
United States as a military juggernaut
intent on world domination
Andrew Bay's a [ __ ] is another
conservative who has recently changed
his mind
unlike Johnson he has not come to
identify with the left but he has come
to agree with its assessment of the
American Empire
he now ridicules the claim that the
promotion of peace democracy and human
rights and the punishment of evildoers
not the pursuit of self-interest has
defined the essence of America and
diplomacy pointing out that the aim of
the US military has been to achieve
something approaching omnipotence base
of itch mocks the idea that such power
in America's hands is by definition
benign
if the American Empire is interpreted in
different ways the same is true all the
more so for the term 9/11 for those
Americans who accept the official
interpretation 9/11 was a surprise
attack on the US government and its
people by Islamic terrorists for some
Americans 9/11 has a more complex
meaning this second group while
accepting the official interpretation of
the attacks thinks of 9/11 primarily as
an event that was used opportunistically
by the Bush administration to extend the
American Empire this interpretation is
effectively presented by writers such as
Noam Chomsky rahul mahajan and Thomas
Johnson for a third group of Americans
the name 9/11 connotes an event with a
more sinister dimension these citizens
believe that the Bush administration
knew the attacks were coming and
intentionally let them happen although
no national poll has been taken to
ascertain how many Americans in general
hold this view azog people in New York
surprisingly indicated that almost half
of the residents of New York City held
that view according to a fourth view of
9/11 the attacks were not merely for
known by the Bush administration they
were orchestrated by it
although thus far no poll has tried to
find out how many Americans hold this
view polls in Canada and Germany taken
some time back indicated that this view
was already held by 15 to 20 percent of
their people
religious people who take the moral
principles of their religious tradition
seriously will probably have very
different attitudes about the American
Empire depending on which of these four
views they hold if they accept the
official view according to which America
was the innocent victim of evil
terrorists then is easy for them to
think of America so-called war on terror
as a just war this is the position taken
by jean bethke Elstein a professor of
ethics at the university of chicago's
Divinity School in a book called just
war against terror from this perspective
the war on terror has nothing to do with
Imperial designs it is simply a war to
save the world from evil terrorists
second interpretation of 9/11 according
to which the Bush administration
cynically exploited the 9/11 attacks to
further its imperial plans has quite
different implications although it
thinks of the attacks as surprise
attacks planned entirely by external
enemies of America it regards these
attacks as blowback for injustice as
perpetrated by US imperialism the second
view typically regards the American
response to the attacks of 9/11 as far
worse than the attacks themselves
they've already led to hundreds of
thousands of deaths this interpretation
of 9/11 would lead people who take their
religions moral principle seriously to
support a movement to change u.s.
foreign policy an even stronger reaction
would be evoked by the third
interpretation for it entails that the
Bush administration allowed thousands of
its own citizens to be killed on 9/11
deliberately and cold-bloodedly for the
sake of advancing its imperial interests
and
use this any event as an excuse to kill
hundreds of thousands of people in other
lands while hypocritically betraying
itself as promoting a culture of life of
course those who accept the previous
interpretation know that hypocrisy with
regard to the sanctity of life has long
been a feature of official u.s. rhetoric
and yet most Americans if they learned
that their government had deliberately
let their own citizens be killed would
surely consider this betrayal
qualitatively different for this would
be treason a betrayal of the oath taken
by American political leaders to protect
their own citizens if this third view
implies that the Bush administration is
guilty of a heinous and even treasonous
crime this is all the more the case with
the fourth view for many Americans the
idea that we are living in a country
whose own leaders planned and carried
out the attacks of 9/11 is simply too
horrible to entertain unfortunately
however there is considerable evidence
for this view and if we find this
evidence convincing the implications for
resistance to the US Empire building
project are radical as basa fish has
emphasized the only remaining debate
about the American Empire is whether it
is benign the interpretation of 9/11 is
relevant to this debate because it would
be very difficult to accept either the
third or the fourth interpretation and
still consider American imperialism
benign so I now turn to some of the
evidence that supports these views
I will look first at evidence that
supports at least the third view
according to which US officials had
foreknowledge of the attacks a central
aspect of the official story about 9/11
is that the attacks were planned
entirely bout by al-qaeda with no one
else knowing the plans a year after the
attacks FBI Director Robert Mueller said
to this day we have found no one in the
United States except the actual
hijackers who knew of the plot since
that time federal officials have had to
admit that they had received far more
warnings prior to 9/11 than they had
previously acknowledged but these
admissions while raising the question of
why further safety measures were not in
place do not necessarily show that the
federal officials had specific
foreknowledge of the attacks one could
still as the 9/11 Commission did accept
the conclusion published at the end of
the 2002 congressional joint inquiries
report which said that none of the
intelligence gathered by the US
intelligence community identified the
time place and specific nature of the
attacks that were planned for September
11th 2001 unfortunately for the official
account however there are reports
indicating that federal officials did
have that very specific kind of
information I will give two examples the
first example involves attorney David
shippers who had been the chief
prosecutor for the impeachment of
President Clinton two days after 9/11
shippers declared that he had received
warnings from FBI agents about the
attack
six weeks earlier warnings that included
both the dates and the targets these
agents had come to him shippers said
because FBI headquarters had blocked
their investigations and had threatened
them with prosecution if they went
public with their information so they
asked shippers to use his influence to
get the government to take action to
prevent the attacks and shippers surely
as the prosecutor of Clinton should have
had influence in Republican circles and
yet he reports that he tried to contact
attorney general Ashcroft and Ashcroft
repeatedly refused to return his calls
shippers allegations about the FBI
agents were then corroborated in a story
by William Norman grig called did we
know what was coming which was published
in the new American a conservative
magazine according to grig the three FAA
the three FBI agents he interviewed told
him that the information provided to
shippers was widely known within the FBI
before September 11th
if shippers Grigg and these agents are
telling the truth it would seem that
when FBI director Mueller claimed that
the FBI had found no one in this country
with advanced knowledge of the plot he
was not telling the truth
the government also would have had
foreknowledge of the attacks because of
an extraordinarily high volume of put
options purchased in the three days
before 9/11 to buy put options for a
particular company is to bet that its
stock price is going to go down these
purchases purchases were for two and
only two Airlines American and United
the two airlines whose planes were used
in the attacks and also for Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter which occupied 22
stories of the World Trade Center the
price of these shares did of course
plummet after 9/11 as the San Francisco
Chronicle said these unusual purchases
which resulted in profits of at least
tens of millions of dollars raised
suspicions that the investors had
advanced knowledge of the strikes for
our purposes the most important
implication of this story follows from
the fact that US intelligence agencies
monitor the market looking for signs of
imminent untoward events these
extraordinary purchases therefore would
have suggested to intelligence agencies
that in the next few days United and
American Airlines airliners were going
to be used in attacks on the world trade
center that is fairly specific knowledge
these two examples then imply the
falsity of the joint inquiry statement
that none of the intelligence gathered
by the US intelligence community
identified the time place and specific
nature of the attacks indeed one of the
FBI agents interviewed by William grig
said obviously people had to know it's
terrible to think this but this must
have been allowed to happen as part of
some other agenda he was right this
would be terrible there is considerable
evidence however that the full truth is
even more terrible that the reason some
officials had foreknowledge of the
attacks is because they had planned them
the evidence for this fourth view
consists of features of the attacks in
conjunction with behavior of US official
that cannot be explained on the
assumption that the attacks were planned
and executed entirely by foreign agents
I will give four examples one feature of
the attacks that suggests complicity by
US officials is the twofold fact that
the US military failed to stop the
attacks on 9/11 and that then since then
they have given us three different
stories as to why they failed these
changing stories suggest that the
military has been trying to cover up the
fact that a stand-down order was given
on 9/11 canceling the military's own
standard operating procedures for
dealing with hijacked airplanes it is
certainly clear that some agency either
the military or the FAA failed to follow
standard procedures on 9/11 when these
procedures are followed the FAA as soon
as it sees signs that a plane may have
been hijacked calls military officials
who then call the nearest Air Force Base
with fighters on alert telling it to
send up a couple of fighters to
intercept the plane such interceptions
usually occur within 10 to 20 minutes
after the first sign of trouble this is
a routine procedure
happening about a hundred times a year
if you've read the story and Popular
Mechanics you know one of their big lies
is oh gee there's only been one such
interception in the last several years
no it's a routine procedure about a
hundred times a year on 9/11 however it
did not happen why not
the military's first story was that no
planes were set up until after the
Pentagon was hit the military leaders
were admitting therefore that they had
left their fighters on the ground for
almost 90 minutes after the FAA
first notice signs of a possible
hijacking this first story suggested to
many people that a stand-down order must
have been given by the end of the week
the military had put out a second story
saying that it had sent up fighters but
that because the FAA had been very late
in notifying it about the hijackings the
fighters arrived too late in each case
one problem with this story is if the
FAA personnel had responded so slowly
heads should have rolled but none did an
even more serious problem is that even
assuming the truth of the late
notification times the military's
fighters still had time to intercept the
hijacked airliners before they were to
hit their targets the second story
implied therefore the standard
procedures had been violated by the
military as well as by the FAA to try to
defend the military against this
accusation the 9/11 Commission report
gave us a third story according to which
the FAA after giving the military
insufficient warning about the first
hijacked airline gave it absolutely no
warning about the other three until
after they had crashed but as I have
pointed out in my second book on 9/11
the 9/11 Commission report omissions and
distortions this account is wholly
implausible
besides portraying the FAA personnel
from top to bottom as incompetent
bumbling dholtze the 9/11 Commission's
account rests on claims that contradict
many credible and mutually supporting
testimonies in some of these cases the
fact that the Commission is simply lying
is obvious in addition the
third-story implies that the military
second-story which had had been telling
for almost three years was almost
entirely false
so if our military leaders were lying to
us all that time why should we believe
them now and if our military is lying to
us must we not assume that it is doing
so to cover up its own guilt in some the
behavior of the military both on 9/11
and afterwards combined with the fact
that the 9/11 Commission had to resort
to lies to make the US military appear
blameless suggests that US military
leaders were complicit in the attacks a
similar conclusion follows from an
examination of the attacks on the
Pentagon one of the debates about this
attack is whether the Pentagon was hit
by American Airlines flight 77 as the
official account says or by military
aircraft either story however implies
that the attack was at least partly an
inside job if we assume that the
Pentagon was struck by flight 77 we must
ask how could this have occurred the
Pentagon is surely the best defended
structure on the face of the planet for
three reasons first it is only a few
miles from Andrews Air Force Base which
has at least three squadrons of fighter
jets on alert at all times to protect
the nation's capital of course part of
the official story is that Andrews was
not keeping any fighters on alert but as
I think I showed convincingly in my book
this story is completely implausible the
second reason the Pentagon is so well
defended is that the US military has the
best radar systems in the world one of
its systems it has bragged does not miss
anything
occurring in North American airspace
this system is also said to be capable
of monitoring a great number of airborne
attack objects simultaneously such as
would be necessary in the case of a
massive military soul attack given that
capability the official story according
to who its flight 77 flew toward the
Pentagon undetected for 30 40 minutes is
absurd
any unauthorized airplane coming towards
the Pentagon would have been detected
and intercepted long before it got close
third the Pentagon is ringed by
anti-missile batteries which are
programmed to destroy any aircraft
entering the Pentagon's
airspace except for any aircraft with a
US military transponder that would
radiate a friendly signal if by some
fluke
flight 77 had entered the Pentagon's
airspace it could have escaped being
shot down only if officials in the
Pentagon had deactivated the
anti-aircraft system so even if we
accept the official story according to
which the Pentagon was hit by flight 77
under the control of al Qaeda hijackers
we must conclude that the attack
succeeded only because the Pentagon
wanted it to succeed but there are many
reasons to reject the official story
first the alleged pilot Hani Hanjour was
widely known as a terrible pilot who
could not possibly have flown the
trajectory of the aircraft that hit the
Pentagon second this aircraft hit the
Pentagon's west wing which would have
been the least likely spot for
terrorists with any intelligence
whatsoever and these guys were supposed
to be so bright they out
picked our whole airforce defense system
they would not have chosen the West Wing
why well in the first place as already
indicated to hit the west wing the the
aircraft had to go through a very
execute a very complex maneuver which
even some experienced pilots would
probably have trouble doing with that
size of an airliner second the West Wing
was being renovated so instead of having
thousands of people in it who would have
been killed it only had a few hundred
and most of them were not military
people they were civilians working on
the renovation thirdly you would think
the terrorists if they hate America and
they wanted to strike at the Pentagon
the symbol of American military strike
they would have one to kill as many of
the top brass and donald rumsfeld
himself they're over in the east wing as
far as you could be away from the west
wing finally the west wing had been via
the renovation involved a great
reinforcement so the damage was much
less to the west wing than it would have
been any other part of the building
another problem with the official story
is that the initial damage to the west
wings facade was far too minimal to have
been caused by the impact of a Boeing
757 forth photographs and eyewitnesses
in the immediate aftermath failed to
provide unambiguous evidence of the
remains of a Boeing 757 v there are
videos that would show whether the
aircraft that struck the Pentagon was in
fact a Boeing 757 but the FBI
confiscated
these videos within minutes after the
attacks and now the authorities have
refused to release them 6 the fact that
the aircraft was not shot down by the
Pentagon's anti-aircraft defense system
suggests that it belonged to the US
military so whether or not the Pentagon
was hit by flight 77 the evidence
suggests it must have been an inside job
we can conclude the same thing about the
attacks on the World Trade Center why
because the collapses of the Twin Towers
and building number seven had to have
been examples of controlled emulation
brought about by thousands of explosives
placed throughout each of the buildings
no foreign terrorists could have
obtained the kind of access to the
buildings this would have required one
reason for concluding that the three
buildings were brought down by explosive
is the very fact that they did collapse
high-rise steel frame buildings have
never before or after 9/11 been caused
to collapse by fire even when as in the
Philadelphia fire of 1999 and the Madrid
fire of February of this year the fires
were much larger much hotter and much
longer lasting than any of the fires in
the World Trade Center
the second reason is the specific nature
of the collapses each feature of which
points to explosives
for example the buildings collapsed
straight down and at virtually freefall
speed as in controlled demolitions and
then the rubble smoldered for months
afterwards with regard to the twin
towers in particular many people in the
buildings said that they saw they felt
or heard explosions virtually all the
concrete of these enormous structures
was pulverized into very fine dust try
this get a piece of concrete and drop it
a little over a thousand feet and see if
it pulverize 'iz into very fine dust it
won't happen much of this dust along
with steel and aluminum was blown out
horizontally from the buildings several
hundred feet most of the steel beams and
columns came down in sections about 30
feet long
conveniently ready to be loaded onto
trucks and pools of Moten's molten steel
were found beneath the rubble these and
even more effects point to the existence
of very powerful precisely placed
explosives a third thing supporting the
theory of controlled demolitions is
evidence of a deliberate cover-up if the
building steel columns and beams had
indeed been broken by explosives an
examination of the steel would have
revealed this fact however although it
is normally a federal offense to remove
anything from a crime scene the steel
was quickly loaded onto trucks and put
on ships headed for Asia to be melted
down
I will mention one more example of the
cover-up insofar as there is an official
story as to why the towers collapsed it
is the pancake theory according to which
the floors above the destruction caused
by the airplanes collapsed on the floor
below and then those floors collapsed on
the floor below that and then it
pancaked all the way down now even if
this theory were remotely plausible can
you imagine it pancaking at freefall
speed the other problem is what happened
to the 47 massive steel columns that
constituted the core of each of these
twin towers they were the weight-bearing
structures of each tower those 40 so
even if the pancake theory were true
those 47 steel beams should have been
sticking up at least several hundred
feet into the air just like the old
photographs where sometimes the 78
records would collapse
but the spindles still sticking up in
the air
you should have forty seven spindles
still sticking up in the air well what
did the 911 Commission report do about
that problem it avoided the problem
incredibly by simply denying the
existence of these columns even though
those columnar I'm not making this up
these colonies columns were the unique
feature of these towers when they were
first built so the Commission report
after saying falsely that most of the
weight of each Tower was borne by the
steel columns in its exterior walls this
supposedly authoritative report said the
interior core of the buildings was a
hollow steel shaft in which elevators
and stair
wells were grouped such a desperate lie
is a sure sign of a cover-up in any case
when we look at all these features of
the collapses the idea that they could
have been caused by the impact of the
airplanes plus the resulting fires is
ridiculous this was even clearer with
regard to building number seven which
wasn't hit by any airplane and yet it
came down about four 5:30 that afternoon
its collapse remains so impossible to
explain except as controlled demolition
that the 9/11 Commission report did not
even mention it as if the collapse of a
forty seven storey building was not
worthy of comment and it only had fires
on floors number seven and 12 of 47
stories in sum the collapses and the
cover-up like the strike on the Pentagon
the military's failure to prevent the
attacks and it's ever-changing stories
show that the attacks must have been
planned and executed by her own
political and military leaders the same
conclusion can be inferred from the
behavior of The Secret Service agents
with the president that morning as
everyone who saw Michael Moore's
Fahrenheit 9/11 knows President Bush was
in a second grade classroom that morning
in Florida when he was informed about
the second strike on the World Trade
Center the first strike he dismissed as
a horrible accident a bad pilot but with
the second one it was clear America was
under an unprecedented terrorist attack
and yet the president simply sat there
many people have asked why he did not
spring into action assuming his role as
commander-in-chief but the real question
which Michael Moore mentioned in passing
is why the Secret Service did not
immediately rush him away
to a safe place bushes location had been
highly publicized and if the attacks
were a complete surprise executed solely
by foreign terrorists the Secret Service
agents would have had no idea how many
planes had been hijacked they would have
had to assume that the President himself
might be the target of one of the
attacks for all they would have known a
hijacked airliner might have been
heading towards them at that very moment
ready to crash into the school and kill
the president and everyone else and yet
these agents who are highly trained to
respond instantly in such situations
allowed the President to remain in the
classroom in other ten minutes they then
allowed him to remain at the school to
give his regularly scheduled TV address
to the nation this behavior makes sense
only if the head of the Secret Service
detail knew that the plans the planned
attacks did not include an attack on the
president
and how could they know this for certain
unless the attacks were being carried
out by people within our own government
although many more examples could be
given these four are sufficient to
suggest that there is no escape from the
frightening conclusion that 9/11 was
engineered by the bush administration
and its Pentagon as to why they would do
this at least part of the answer is
clear from the way in which they have
used 9/11 to advance the American Empire
immediately after 9/11 in fact members
of the Bush administration repeatedly
referred to the attack the attacks as an
opportunity in the words of donald
rumsfeld an opportunity to refashion the
world seeing this connection between
9/11 in the american empire can be a
stimulus to face up fully to the awful
truth
about this Empire to be sure as Chomsky
Falk and Chalmers Johnson Illustrated
very strong portrayals of American
Empire imperialism as far from benign
can be drawn without any suggestion that
the Bush administration arranged 9/11
these portrayals can be drawn from
publicly available documents one such
document is the national security
strategy of the United States of America
published by the Bush administration in
September of 2002 David North says not
unfairly that this document asserts as
the guiding policy of the United States
the right to use military force against
any country it believes to be or
believes at some point may become a
threat to American interests no other
country in modern history adds north has
asserted such a sweeping claim to world
domination another such document called
vision for 2020 was published in
February of 1997 by the US Space Command
the mission statement at the head of
this document reads US Space Command
dominating the space dimension of
military operations to protect us
interests and investments nothing about
freedom democracy and human rights in
the body of the document in fact we find
this amazingly candid statement the
globalization of the world economy will
continue with a widening between haves
and have-nots the point of this
statement is that as the domination of
the world economy by the United States
and its allies increases the world's
poor will get still poor
making the have-nots hate America all
the more we will need therefore the
power to keep them in line the united
states can do this and this is the
documents main message through full
spectrum dominance which will involve
merging space superiority with land sea
and air superiority dominance in space
will include the document frankly says
the power to deny others the use of
space by speaking only of the space
commands effort to develop a missile
defense system the Pentagon and the
White House like to suggest that its
purpose is purely defensive but the goal
includes weaponizing space so as to give
US forces in the words of a more recent
document a prompt Global Strike
capability whether nuclear or
non-nuclear that will allow the u.s. to
rapidly and accurately strike distant
targets the fact that the US Space
Command program is an aggressive one is
announced in the logo of one of its
divisions in your face from outer space
simply from these and other documents
taken in conjunction with the actions of
the Bush administration and the US
military we can see through the claim
that the u.s. project of creating the
first truly global Empire is a
benevolent or even benign Enterprise
however we can fully grasp the extent to
which this project is propelled by
fanaticism based on a deeply perverted
value system only when we realize that
the terrorist attacks of 9/11 were
orchestrated by our own leaders and that
they did this to provide the
justification the fear and the funding
for the so-called war on
terror which would be used at the
pretext for enlarging the Empire I will
illustrate this point with one of the
most brazen examples of the use of 911
to get funding shortly before the
current Bush administration took office
about a year before a document entitled
rebuilding America's defenses was
published by an organization called the
project for the new American Century
founding members of which included Dick
Cheney Paul Wolfowitz and Donald
Rumsfeld this document focused primarily
on getting more tax monies allocated for
the technological transformation of the
US military with the centerpiece of this
technological transformation being the
US Space command's project to weaponize
and thereby control space because this
transformation of the u.s. military will
be very expensive the document said it
will probably proceed very slowly unless
America suffers some catastrophic and
catalyzing event like a new Pearl Harbor
it is interesting that then on the night
of 9/11 itself
President Bush reportedly wrote in his
diary the Pearl Harbor of the 21st
century took place today in any case
earlier that evening Secretary of
Defense Rumsfeld was on message we might
assume he would have be would have been
disoriented by the fact that the
Pentagon had just under his watch
suffered an unprecedented attack instead
he was ready to use the attacks to
obtain more money for the US Space
Command he had just before taking office
in fact chaired the Commission about the
US Space Command popularly known as the
Rumsfeld Commission that evening of 9/11
itself
in front of television cameras Rumsfeld
berated Senator Carl Levin
then chairman of the Senate Armed
Services Committee saying senator Levin
you and other Democrats in the Congress
have voiced fear that you simply don't
have enough money for the large
increases in defense that the Pentagon
is seeking especially for missile
defense does this sort of thing convince
you that an emergency exists in this
country to increase defense spending the
strategy worked Congress immediately
appropriated an additional 40 billion
for the Pentagon
since then furthermore the president has
gotten every additional appropriation he
has sought for the so-called war on
terror besides being a rousing success
in obtaining increased spending for
military purposes 9/11 also provided the
pretext for putting many military bases
in Central Asia the big new Brzezinski
in his 1997 book the great the grand
chessboard had said that doing so would
be crucial for maintaining American
primacy partly because of the huge oil
reserves around the Caspian Sea indeed
the project for the new American Century
may have gotten its idea that a new
Pearl Harbor would be helpful from this
book
Brzezinski explaining that the American
public had supported America's
engagement in World War two largely
because of the shock effect of the
Japanese attack on Pearl Harbor
suggested that Americans today would
support the needed military operations
in Central Asia only in the circumstance
of a truly massive and widely perceived
direct external threat and indeed thanks
to the attacks of 9/11 the Bush
administration was able to carry out its
plan
to attack Afghanistan a plan that we now
know had been formulated several months
before 9/11 the White House now has a
friendly government in Afghanistan and
the Pentagon has military bases there
and in several of the other countries in
Central Asia we also know that the
intention to invade Iraq
existed long before 9/11 and that this
intention was based on Imperial designs
not discussed with Saddam's wickedness
in the project for the new American
Century two thousand and two thousand
document we read while the unresolved
conflict with Iraq provides the
immediate justification the need for a
substantial American force presence in
the Gulf transcends the issue of the
regime of Saddam Hussein the US military
is now intending to build several
permanent bases in Iraq which has the
world's second largest known supply of
oil reserves the attacks of 9/11 again
provided the pretext as the Bush
administration deceived a majority of
the American people into believing that
Saddam was connected with Osama bin
Laden and even directly responsible for
the attacks of 9/11 I suggested earlier
that seeing the true connections between
9/11 and the global domination project
helps us understand how fully this
project reflects fanaticism based on a
deeply perverted value system this is a
value system that is diametrically
opposed to the value systems on which
all the great religious and moral
traditions of the world have been based
these traditional value systems say that
we should not covet steal and murder
that we should make sure that everyone
has the necessary means for a decent
life but our governments project for
a globe for global domination is carried
out in the name of the haves of the
world who want still more even if it
means killing hundreds of thousands of
people and letting millions more die
every year because of starvation and
other poverty related diseases we can
now see furthermore that some political
and military leaders are so fanatically
infected with these perverted values
that they are willing to kill thousands
of their own citizens then endlessly use
a deceptive account of these terrorist
attacks to justify a war on terror in
the name of which they claim the right
to do virtually anything they wish
ignoring all principles of international
law and morality I turn now finally to
the question how should religious people
respond to 9/11 and the American Empire
my discussion of this question must be
very brief consisting merely of four
suggestions first discover and then
speak the truth I would suggest that
religious people should if they have not
done also already study about both 9/11
and the American Empire to see if they
find the claims I have made here true if
they do then they should do everything
they can to make others aware of these
facts second create new means to spread
the truth it is clear that the
mainstream press in America is complicit
in the cover-up of the truth about the
American Empire in general and 9/11 in
particular for example my second book
which exposes many outrageous lies has
not been reviewed by a single mainstream
newspaper magazine television station so
on there are of course alternative
publications both in print and on the
Internet
that seek to expose the truth about the
American Empire most of these however
failed to deal with 9/11 and most of
them are indifferent to or even hostile
to religion so they do not have provide
effective organs to communicate with
religious communities perhaps the most
important thing that religious groups
concerned with getting the truth about
9/11 out could do is to create new means
of communication means through which the
contrast between the values of the
religious traditions and the values of
the global domination project can be
made clear on this basis an ecumenical
religious movement to oppose the global
domination project partly by exposing
the truth about 9/11 might be formed
third formulate proposals for subverting
the global domination project as such a
movement begins to form it will need to
decide rather concretely how to go about
trying to subvert the global domination
project another thing we need from
religious thinkers of the various
traditions therefore our proposals for
how to do this I will soon be publishing
I hope my own proposal which is centered
around the idea of global democracy
other people will favor different
proposals but I stressed the importance
of having proposals from religious
thinkers it is probably only such
proposals drawing explicitly on the
moral principles of the religious
traditions that will have the power to
move large numbers of people around the
world fourth form alliances with other
moral nongovernmental organizations
generally called
NGOs I have emphasized that it is
important for representatives from the
various religious
to join forces indeed my motto is
religions of the world unite you have
nothing to lose but your impotence but
it is essential at the same time for
these religious groups to forge
alliances with what we can call the
other moral NGOs of the world whether
they are working for human rights for
peace for ecological sustainability or
some related cause the moral principles
that motivate these NGOs are
diametrically opposed to the values of
the global domination project by
emphasizing the moral principles that we
have in common
organizations that are and are not
explicitly religious can join forces in
opposing that radically immoral project
I will close with the observation that
insofar as Americans participate in this
anti-imperial movement their activities
will be deeply patriotic because they
will be seeking to call our nation back
to its moral ideals which stand
our moral ideals which stand
diametrically opposed to the values
implicit in the global domination
project thank you very much for your
time
okay
and thank you for coming out on this
very warm evening okay we we got lots of
questions um I apologize to those who
would have preferred a more chaotic pick
and choose and point method which I have
been reminded is some common practice at
these lectures and I all I can say is
that we did it this way in part because
we have so many questions it'll be hard
to get through the ones that we do have
and you know you you also avoid the
people rambling problem and we are on TV
so we have I'm going through these they
they just about all look good
everybody in Madison is above average
just like in Lake Wobegon oh go ahead
okay first one these are pretty random
actually because as I said they're all
good my 15 year old daughter wanted to
be here but she's in Spanish at a
Spanish test tomorrow the quit her
question is the US military is running
out of troops a draft seems to be in the
offing but probably wouldn't be accepted
by the people without another 911 type
event WMD attack perhaps do you see
signs of this coming as a very
frightening thought coming from a 15
year old and Nitz knows what's going on
because the problem is as she suggests
if a draft is started then we do have
Vietnam and they stayed that's what they
learned if you have a draft then you get
movements on University campuses that
get a lot of publicity and they don't
want that so they've tried using high
tech technology but boy when you invade
and occupy you need a lot of troops as
they learned so they tried mercenaries
but the mercenaries from the other
countries are mostly going home now so
what are we going to do so I'm afraid
she's right that the thought of another
new new Pearl Harbor may be maybe an
option perish the thought there is the
thought okay next what is your opinion
of my crew purtz work in crossing the
Rubicon specifically about mock fake
military exercises
with live fly hijacking exercises and
radar inserts yeah
Michael Rupert is one of the great
heroes of the 9/11 movement he was tough
you know he was there long before most
everybody else was Paul Thompson's great
time line that got me started Paul gives
Michael Rupert credits as he got started
with Michael with regard to that
particular thesis it's it's one that I
have not studied sufficiently to have
what I would call a really informed
opinion on it it's certainly very
interesting that these exercises were
going on but as exactly what role they
played that morning I'm just fairly
agnostic when it comes to Rupert's more
particular thesis about Chaney being the
one who was in charge that morning and
calling the shots that seems very clear
so we're clearly one on that and I just
say on the other I think it's probably
very significant but I couldn't say
anything more about it okay next one a
common question that we conspiracy
theorists here an inside job of this
magnitude involves the conspiracy of a
lot of people how come there is no leak
nobody cracking nothing thank you yeah
let me say a word about the term
conspiracy theory you know it's it's
become almost an oath of being an
American to say oh I don't believe in
conspiracy theories but of course your
newspaper every day is filled with
stories of conspiracies whenever two or
more people get together to do something
illegal or immoral that's a conspiracy
and if you've got an idea of what
happened you have a conspiracy theory so
we all have we all are believers in
conspiracy theories and the official
story about 9/11 is the mother of all
9/11 conspiracy theories this is a
theory that these night
arab-muslim hijackers without any help
from anybody in the United States
out-tricked our trillion dollar military
defense system and pull this off and
knocked down these buildings
well the question is not whether you
believe in a conspiracy theory or not
but which theory stands up to the
evidence another thing to to point out
is that as James Pfitzer philosophers
science who's now getting involved in
the 9/11 truth movement has pointed out
theory is sometimes a very strong word
we have the theory of gravitation
you know relativity theory we have
quantum theory these are very precise
theories the point is they're testable a
conspiracy theory is fine if it's
testable well fortunately the
government's theory is testable you can
test can steel frame high-rise buildings
fall down solely because of fire and
they've actually done experiments to try
this and they've never been able to get
a building to even come close to
collapsing so it's a testable theory
which has been falsified and I've
indicated several other aspects that are
I think clear falsifications of the
official theory now the question all
sorts of questions can be then raised
sort of all priori questions well why
would they do this and I raise some of
those in my book if you read what
Chapter 9 of the new Pearl Harbor there
are lots of puzzling questions I thought
the first question is going to be we
know what happened to Barbara Olson and
that's always the first one I don't know
there are all of these things and so is
it possible that very many people could
be involved in a conspiracy and keep it
silent for a long time well yes remember
the Manhattan Project a lot of people
were involved in that and that was kept
secret for a long time
and we've looked back now we know that
lots of previous conspiracies were kept
silent for a long time
america's first attack in indonesia we
had a full-scale war going on there and
until a book was published on it in the
late 90s hardly any americans knew about
it it was kept secret for a very long
time if you add to the fact that we do
have other instances the fact that
people many of the people involved are
our government or and military and other
government employees who take an oath
like these FBI guys they've taken an
oath of obedience if they violate that
see they want they they they're hoping
shippers could I don't know what's
happening now but originally they were
evidently hoping that shippers could get
a trial so they could be subpoenaed in
which case they would have to testify
and that would free them from
prosecution but if they just come out
and talk then they're prosecuted they
said sent to prison for the rest of
their lives maybe they can't support
their families and then in some cases
people are told well you know Joe if you
start talking about this somebody's
going to get really mad at you and I
don't know how we're going to protect
your wife and kids would you talk
particularly when there's no reception
there's nobody asking you to come
forward did the 9/11 Commission make a
general appeal and say please if you've
got any information on this come and
talk to us no nobody was invited other
than government employees and so if you
go to the the mainstream media they
ridicule you so who's going to risk
their their family's life to come
forward so no I am NOT surprised that a
rather large number of people could be
involved and also you know we have
previous examples of things that went on
and people who knew
got killed how many in people who had
apparently had some knowledge about
JFK's assassination ended up dead a lot
of people know about that so they know
what can happen so no I'm not surprised
but the fact is that nevertheless some
people are trying to come forward these
FBI agents Sibel Edmonds is been trying
to come forward and tell her story for
many many months now as I report in my
book on the 9/11 Commission report she
testified to the Commission for three
and a half hours she told them very
specific things she's since then written
a public letter to an open letter to
chairman Kane reminding him of what she
told the Commission such as that their
Iranian asset had told them that Elle
sama bin lot he was an expert on
Afghanistan that Osama bin Laden was
planning an attack in the United States
pretty soon the translator who got that
information was told to keep quiet
within the FBI
she told the FBI about that that other
translator told the FBI and his
two-and-a-half hours of testimony
none of that appears in the 9/11
Commission report all that you learned
that Sibel Edmonds one tiny little note
says that she had some suggestions that
FBI should follow its own policies a
little more closely that's all you
learned from her three and a half hours
of testimony so she has been coming
trying to come forward and some other
people too and they've lost their jobs
so people are ok here's a question on
source validation methodology who are
your sources and what standards did you
employ to validate these sources yeah in
the in the new Pearl Harbor I did rely
primarily on the four sources that I
cited the most elements Nafees omits
book but he relied also a lot
Paul Thompson and also use Michelle
Joseph dusky the economist in Canada
Paul Thompson one thing interesting
about his time line and now he's
published his book as the terror
timeline he used only main line sources
so New York Times Boston Globe The
Guardian
London Times so on I don't even think he
quoted the nation I mean he really stuck
to what are considered really mainline
sources and yet found hundreds of
stories that contradicted the official
account as to method you know it's very
differently you just have to learn to
trust your you're kind of educated
judgment I've gotten into a lot of
previous fields my my work at the Center
for process studies called for me to
organize conferences in a lot of fields
philosophy of physics Eastern religions
Chinese religions Asian Buddhist
Hinduism Buddhism political theory
economic theory so in each case I had to
go in and start reading around and
learning who were the generally
considered respectable writers and then
who were the ones who maybe weren't so
respectable but we're good and had
something important to say outside the
mainstream and so on so I think method
is is in that sense more of a sort of
trained judgment about these things and
of course people can differ on these
things that I did and I limited myself
to stories that I found to be at least
highly plausible but I did not commit
myself and those of you have read the
book to say I know these stories are
true I mean there are hundreds of
stories there and a single researchers
like myself or Paul Thompson we don't
have the resources
so what we're calling on is we're saying
there is a prima facie case here for a
genuine investigation we've got
organizations that have the money
to carry out organ investigations like
that
they're called the US Congress they're
called the US media which have billions
of dollars
so the question is what method are they
using ignoring for whether it's worth
David I handed US Senator Russ Feingold
your book two weeks ago and he promised
to look into it
I've had a lot of promises promises
promises promises okay no sungold is a
good guy I bet he'll do it
I actually urged him to take up this and
in hopes of a Feingold McKinney ticket
next next election if there is one an
election okay where do we go from here
how do we get through to a brainwashed
electorate led by money in power next
question we invite c-span absolutely
right this is really a historic event
you know when the hearings were being
were going on c-span covered those and
covered some of the discussions that
occurred afterwards with some of the
9/11 families and Kyle hints of 9/11
citizens movement was able to make a
statement which c-span did cover and so
that did get conveyed to the American
people but to my knowledge
maybe c-span can correct maybe to my
knowledge this is the first event in
which this kind of major presentation
the full hour presentation has been made
and covered so this might be the
beginning of something big we'll see
about
okay we've got room for four more
questions at the top of the deck
specifics isn't it true that CIA
officials met with Osama bin Laden when
he was being operated on in a hospital
shortly before 9/11 this seems to be
true it was reported by a very reputable
Swiss journalist and picked up by
several European newspapers including
some British newspapers by just
accidentally I guess by no American
newspaper but that in July of 2001 when
Osama bin Laden was already the number
one wanted man in the world the report
is that he went to a hospital in Dubai
the American Hospital was treated by an
American surgeon and visited by the
local CIA agent as well as by the head
of Saudi intelligence so it appears that
this is one of the many of the stories I
tell in the new Pearl Harbor that
suggests that the relationship between
the Bush family and the bin Laden family
isn't maybe exactly what we've been told
and of course we have a full-length book
on that house of Bush House of Saud and
in fact let me say a word about that
that part of Michael Moore's movie guys
I'm blanking on the guy's name who wrote
the house of Bush hunger Craig Unger
Craig Unger yeah I was very grateful he
responded with me on this and if you
remember after the movie when Michael
Moore's movie got trashed so much by
mainline critics
movie critics telling him he didn't know
what he was talking about they said that
this idea that any Saudi flights were
allowed to go before other side flights
were allowed to go was just false and
what Craig Unger had reported was that
on the February excuse-me September 13th
two days after 9/11 there was a flight
that took some young Saudis from Tampa
to Lexington and Lexington was one of
the places where a big plane was going
to take a number of them
bin Laden's and other Saudis out of the
country and Craig Unger stressed that
this flight left before private flights
were allowed to go in the United States
now he emphasized that at 11 o'clock
that morning American airspace was open
to commercial planes but not too private
and there was a special notice sent out
that says this is only for commercial
flights if any private flights go up
they will be forced out nevertheless
that flight went at 4:30 that afternoon
and was not forced down they had
permission to go now the 9/11 Commission
who proves that story and says oh there
was no problem because American airspace
was opened at 9 at 11 o'clock
deliberately ignoring the distinction
Craig younger made very explicitly both
in his book and in a I think it was a
Wall Street Journal article the
distinction between commercial and
private flights so Michael Moore was
right Craig Unger was right on that
short of outright illegal disclosures
will it ever prove possible to create a
culture of accountability and
transparency with respect to the so
called intelligence community well many
people believe that sort of the
beginning of the end of the American
Republic happened when the intelligence
Act was was created there after World
War two and the CIA was created now it
did follow from a previous organization
the OSS but still it had more powers and
these intelligence agencies now have
enormous budgets there are many of these
intelligence agencies so the CIA is just
one of what eleven major intelligence
agencies so you have several each
military branch has to have its own and
so when you talk about what percentage
of the American budget goes to military
affairs you know even the official
budget the official amount is very high
but you really need to factor in a lot
of money that does not usually is not
usually considered military spending so
if you factored in just the budgets for
the intelligence agencies you is an
enormous amount I don't have the exact
figure and nobody does it's a secret but
people who are in the know speculate
that is a very very high figure well
when you have that kind of money with no
accountability you have you know Lord
Acton was certainly right and you know
he was a good Catholic he was just
carrying out the what Christians have
called the doctrine of original sin
which is really the doctrine of
originating sin when he said and it's
very important to get the exact words
correctly it's usually misquoted but he
says he said power tends to corrupt an
absolute power corrupts absolutely
in the second one note ins to absolute
power corrupts absolutely and we have a
military and a set of intelligence
agency now that have virtually absolute
power as I understand that there have
been some neocon purges recently that is
purchase by not of neo-cons
and so if any of you recently unemployed
agents are sitting around with nothing
better to do than watch c-span you might
give us a call and tell us some of your
stories and join join this great new
organization yes right
and the last one do 9/11 widows fully
accept as true the 9/11 Commission
report no on that thank you for it for
an easy easy question and I think I I
think I can say safely that in the
future you will see some of the 9/11
family members becoming more outspoken
than they've been in the past well again
thank you very much for coming out on
this
David Ray Griffin is Professor emelius
at the Claremont School of Theology
where we taught for over 30 years the
9/11 Commission report omissions and
distortions is published by Olive Branch
press an imprint of interlink publishing
visit